le napoléon de la chanson n'est plus
tino rossi s'est éteint à l'âge de 76
ans qu'on sait des ministres le
gouvernement dissout la consulte des
comités nationaliste un mouvement
indépendantiste corse considérée comme
la vitrine légale de l'ex flnc
les négociations sur les oeuvres au
missile moscou juge inacceptables les
nouvelles propositions américaines
assoupi annoncé hier par le président
reagan aux nations unies australienne de
remporte l'america's cup les états unis
en deuil d'une régate et l'australie en
délire
à
ah ah
lui tandis que la bière
avec cela n'aurait
hélas
dans ce temps là bas
oh
madame monsieur bonsoir pendant 50 ans
et pour quatre générations
sa voix et son oeil de velours avait
fait de lui le napoléon de la chanson
d'amour de l'amour heureux bien sûr car
tino rossi croyait au bonheur il s'est
éteint ce matin à paris à l'âge de 76
ans jean jeu bégoux évoque pour nous la
personnalité de celui qui déjà de son
vivant depuis longtemps et est un
monument de la chanson française
au vieux chevaux
ce bateau
on
entre en ciel changeant
50 ans de succès ça ne se raconte pas ça
se chante et hino n'était pas bavard ses
amis parler pour lui marcel pagnol
disait que ses chansons étaient les
journaux intimes de ceux qui n'en
tiennent pas il fut selon raymond
castans le petit fiancée de la france on
se mourait d'amour pour lui dans la rue
au restaurant des femmes se jeter dans
ses bras
c'est tout le monde le connaissait et
les mains du public populaire à l'élite
intellectuelle et politique certains
irréductibles comme georges bernanos
considéré que cette voie était
l'avachissement de la france trois soirs
de suite à 1000 fois la loge 3000 da et
pourtant cette voie a séduit envoûté
depuis le premier succès au casino de
paris en 1934 en passant par les films
et les opérettes des années 50
bravo à mon tour de l'autre
pour art tout le temps moi
ça vous ennuie pas que je m'arrête il
seconde
qu'est ce que l'ex homme fort merci
quand même toujours aimable tout va bien
savoir ce que je vous ai fait rien vous
devez vous marier avec louis et alors
alors je trouve dans le côtoyer tout le
temps autour de moi les yeux manque de
lui c'est là que je veux est un
territoire
jamais une femme de 80 ans alors
pourquoi se fait en taille pour rien
pourtant le salon je me dégoûte
causerie d'amour
mais où j'ai vu le jour
si tu veux durer chante l'amour lui
conseiller vincent scotto et inuh le
s'en priva pas dans ses ritournelles
mais il chanta aussi la corse
ils firent rayonner partout ensoleillé
enjolivé bien sûr mais présente est
solidement ancrée en lui
bonjour
le encore
dans ce fil
mo
au travers
la foi en dieu ne le quitta jamais et le
jour nous avons tourné ces images en 79
pour le centenaire de bernadette
soubirous qui nous était très ému
là
vol
250 millions de disques 25 films et des
centaines d'émissions de télévision
demeure afin de nous rappeler qu'il
était une fois un chanteur corse fils de
tailleur qui pacifiquement armée de
charme et de talent a réussi la plus
impériale des conquêtes celle des coeurs
les obsèques religieuses de tino rossi
seront célébrées jeudi matin à paris en
l'église de la madeleine
il sera enterré vendredi ajaccio dans sa
terre natale
le président mitterrand dans un message
de condoléances adressé à sa famille a
rendu hommage à la qualité de son art et
de sa personne et toutes sortes de
français des plus connues au plus
anonymes ont exprimé leur émotion à
l'annoncé de sa disparition
jean marc dubois dell annonce de sa mort
il était là à son domicile
monsieur est un homme charmant il avait
tout pour lui tout pour lui
c'est une très grosse perte croyez le
bien que vous aimiez ces gens sont cons
par monsieur j'avais beaucoup
d'admiration pour lui c'était de plus un
homme qui était resté très simple et
naturelle on peut une expression en
vulgaire et n'a pas pris la grosse tête
parce qu'il avait du succès l eau est
polluée que le christ de sa mort
ce match c'est vraiment triste je
m'efforce à ne pas céder s'écouler mais
la malbrande franchement je suis plus je
suis emparé il vraiment mais j'ai perdu
des parents mais pas comme ça oui
il a gardé son style de chansons pendant
toute sa carrière on peut pas le lui
enlever quoi
il n'allait pas du jour au lendemain a
chanté les problèmes de la côte bleue
forêt certains certains groupes car ce
sont eux comme unique dans la chanson
française moi je ne connais pas d'autres
50 ans à un tête d'affiche bon je suis
pas triste mais j'ai un peu de peine
mais je sais que commencer il est pas
parti en fait c'était toujours assez
drôle de le voir assez extraordinaire de
le voir assez à c'est un peu gros comme
ça venir à la télévision chanter le
petit papa noël c'était une image assez
assez extraordinaire voilà c'est la mort
quoi c'est chiant dans notre dernier
journal à 23h40 claude sérillon
consacrera une page spéciale au chanteur
disparu
deux semaines après l'assassinât en
corse de pierre-jean massimi une semaine
après la revendication du meurtre par
l'ex flnc le gouvernement sur
instigation du ministre de l'intérieur
gaston defferre contre attaque
réunis ce matin en conseil des ministres
le gouvernement a mis hors la loi
la consulte des comités nationaliste un
mouvement indépendantiste considéré
comme la vitrine légale du front de
libération nationale de la corse
lui-même officiellement dissous en
janvier dernier sur place en corse paul
le fait 9 juillet 83 ajaccio la ccn
appel à manifester pour protester contre
la disparition du jeune nationaliste guy
orsoni et accuse un ministre en exercice
joseph franceschi de l'avoir en quelque
sorte commandité un nouveau défi des
nationalistes à l'état défi qui est à la
base de la dissolution d'aujourd'hui la
consulte des comités nationaliste a été
créé en empruntant 81 par l'union des
douze mouvement nationaliste existant en
corse le 15 juillet 83 7 des principaux
dirigeants sont inculpés de complicité
de reconstitution de ligue dissoute
allusion au flnc
parmi eux inculpés ft l'a condamné à 15
ans de prison 80 par la cour de sûreté
de l'état est libéré par la notion de 81
pour le voit il est assujetti à un
contrôle judiciaire ça se passait hier
soir bastia quelques heures avant la
dissolution question qu'allez vous ferme
à seyssel a toujours été un mouvement
public son action a toujours été légal
donc notre réponse sera celle que
permettent aujourd'hui une action
publique est légal mais de toute manière
nous ne pouvons pas nous empêcher de
considérer que cette dissolution est
tout d'abord une très grave atteinte aux
délits d'opinion aux délits d'opinion
nationaliste en particulier que le
gouvernement est tombé dans le piège que
lui a tendu les forces clanique
en acceptant de rejeter la seule force
réelle de propositions qui existent en
corse et enfin cela dénoterait une
volonté politique de marginaliser
peut-être de militariser la lutte
nationaliste afin de pouvoir exercer
contre elle une répression très dure
justifiée par une provocation montée de
toutes pièces risque de militariser il
est là déjà rappelez-vous 10 juillet 83
aveiro petit village près d'ajaccio pose
d'une plaque à la mémoire de guy orsoni
un commando spectacle du flnc plus la
présence active de la cgn nouveau défi à
l'état ou pouvoir central mais aussi
défi aux systèmes politiques corses dont
l'un des membres ce soir c'est pau
je vais peut-être me singulariser mais
je crois que cette décision me semble
dans le comté ça tu l as et inopportune
parce qu'il faut éviter à l'heure
actuelle encore de prendre des mesures
qui paraît prêt sanctionner un délit
d'opinion pour d'autant moins le faire
que ce gouvernement et vous le savez
parfaitement monsieur lefebvre a fait
voter les lois d'amnistié a supprimé les
juridictions déception et a instauré en
corse un débat démocratique d'une d'une
dimension exceptionnelle la presse
parlée écrite télévisée les murs même le
sens vont s'en font l'écho
même si quelquefois certains sont blancs
ils rythment notre coeur et notre raison
je crois donc qu'il ne saurait y avoir
aujourd'hui encore de délit d'opinion il
faut simplement est strictement à
veiller à ce que les opinions
s'expriment par la seule voie légale et
démocratique sans tolérer le moindre
débordement
je pense pour ma part que cette mesure
n'aura pas n'aura pas de conséquences et
peut-être me s'imposer par la rencontre
s est tué lakoun soutenir wydad et
nationalistes comptent en doute après
une période d'attenté les nationalistes
vont il sert goûter sous un nouveau nom
par exemple la consulte des
nationalistes corses cnc rien donc ne
semble avoir fondamentalement changé ce
soir dans le climat politique de la
corse avant l'annoncé de la dissolution
de la csn ministre de l'intérieur gaston
defferre s'était entretenu hier avec les
représentants de l'état en corse dans le
commissaire broussard et il avait reçu
dimanche dernier les principaux élus de
l'île
cet après midi le porte parole du
gouvernement max gallo a résumé les
commentaires faits à ce propos ce matin
par le chef de l'état et le premier
ministre
le premier ministre a indiqué en
commentant cette décision que il
s'agissait d'appliquer avec rigueur la
loi républicaine le président de la
république pour sa part a indiqué que
cette fermeté et cette rigueur était
nécessaire dès lors que le gouvernement
de la république avait mis en place au
terme d'élections qui s'étaient
déroulées de la manière
la plus démocratique qui soit des
organismes représentatifs
parallèlement au travail du commissaire
broussard en corse et à son insu le gign
aurait été à l'oeuvre en corse le
capitaine baril a ainsi rencontré en
janvier dernier alain orsoni le frère du
militant indépendantiste disparu en juin
c'est ce que révèle le canard enchaîné
le capitaine barril agi de sa propre
initiative a dicté en ce soir de source
autorisée
mise à part la situation en corse
l'essentiel du conseil des ministres de
ce matin a été consacré à l'examen des
projets gouvernementaux dans le domaine
de l'informatique et de l'électronique
c'est la place de la france dans le
monde à la fin du xxème et au début du
21e siècle qui est en jeu a déclaré le
chef de l'état
le développement de l'informatique dans
l'enseignement et la priorité a signé à
l'électronique pour la modernisation
d'industrie ont fait l'objet de
communication des ministres concerne
c'est une confirmation l'indicé des prix
de détail a augmenté de 0,6 pour cent en
août selon le chiffre définitif de
l'insee un chiffre qui selon le
ministère des finances confirme le
ralentissement des prix même s'il reste
insuffisant puisque le pari du
gouvernement de limiter l'inflation à 8%
cette année ne peut plus être tenus le
ministère table désormais sur un taux de
8,5 pour cent pour 83 depuis le début de
l'année l'inflation est de 6,8 pour cent
et sur les douze derniers mois la hausse
est de 9,7 pouces
ouverture aujourd'hui à divonne les
bains des journées parlementaires de
l'udf la sphère de dreux a dominé les
débats puisque madame simone veil
première invitée de ces journées avant
raymond barre qui parlent ce soir et
valéry giscard d'estaing jeudi madame
simone veil a été prise à partie pour
avoir exprimé ses distances face à
l'alliance conclue par l'opposition au
second tour avec le front national sur
place jean-louis le scène
quand l'udf était le principal soutien
du gouvernement et du président de la
république les élus à quelques
exceptions près parlait d'une seule et
même voix
aujourd'hui il en va tout différemment
et simone veil la première invitée de
marque de ces journées parlementaires de
divonne l'a appris ce matin à ses dépens
venu parler de l'europe est
exclusivement de l'europe
elle a été prise à partie pour son appel
à l'abstention au moment des municipales
partielles de dreux confusion à l'udf
disent les uns débat démocratique nous
ressemblons au parti socialiste d'avant
80 affirme les autres toujours est il
que madame veil a dû se justifier qu'il
y ait tant de gens je ne parle pas dans
l'électorat mais je parle parmi le monde
politique qui ait pu penser que
j'approuvais tel que je suis cette
alliance avec le front national
je dois dire que je m'en étonne jeunes
en étonne parce que tout le monde a
toujours considéré dans le pays depuis
la deuxième guerre mondiale que ce
n'était pas une formation politique de
l'opposition comme les autres
la preuve en est la décision prise par
monsieur chirac sans aucune hésitation
lors des élections municipales du mois
de mars jamais on a considéré qu'on
pouvait faire ce type d'alliance avec
l'extrême droite sans que ça ait des
conséquences sur la stratégie politique
générale de l'udf et quelle importance à
de prendre quatre personnes alors que ça
représente sur le plan de la stratégie
et sur le plan de la morale politique
une un changement considérable imaginons
même qu'il y ait eu un risque de perdre
eux qui à mon avis n'existait pas
mais est ce que ça ne valait pas la
peine de perdre même deux et je veux
pouvoir continuer et continuer sans
cesse à dénoncer l'alliance dès que des
socialistes et communistes a dénoncé la
présence des communistes au sein du
gouvernement et a dénoncé comme je le
fais sans cesse au parlement européen
toutes les annonces de ce genre toutes
les manifestations non démocratique et
tous les extrémismes quel qu'il soit
nous sommes engagés dans un combat
politique sud était grave à dreux
c'est nos avions perdu mais il faut
aussi
il faut nous n'avons pas moralement
perdu en tout cas 55 % du corps
électoral ont préféré voter pour la
liste de monsieur you en démocrate
nous devons aussi le reconnaître même si
l'intégralité et la composition de la
liste ne nous plaît pas ce que
volontiers je t'accorde simone veil
fidèle à ses convictions
proche de la majorité sur certains
dossiers en revanche farouchement dans
l'opposition sur l'europe par exemple
une vedette chassant l'autre c'est
raymond barre qui a pris la suite de
madame veil
l'ancien premier ministre lui aussi
persiste et signe il la vit sur
l'économie cet après midi il le redira
ce soir sur la cohabitation impossible
entre chef de l'état et chef du
gouvernement deux tendances opposées
pour une formation qui essaye depuis
quelques temps de resserrer les rangs on
peut constater que l'udf depuis ce matin
place paradoxalement sous les
projecteurs de personnalités qui veulent
tout de garder leur liberté d'action
madame simone veil a par ailleurs parlé
longuement de l'europe dans son discours
d'aujourd'hui et dénoncer à la fois la
montée du pacifisme et l'évolution des
partis socialistes dans différents pays
européens
la cfdt s'engage dans le pacifisme vieux
syndicat a décidé de rejoindre le comité
pour le désarmement nucléaire en europe
qui regroupe des organisations
indépendantes du parti communiste
français simple manoeuvre de propagande
c'est ainsi que moscou réagit
aujourd'hui aux dernières propositions
américaines pour faire aboutir un genève
les négociations sur les euromissiles le
président reagan les avait exposé hier
devant l'assemblée générale des nations
unies et les avait qualifiées de
propositions de paix à destination de
l'union soviétique
les explications de georges bortoli mais
d'abord de new york
edouard l'heure pour la première fois
depuis 25 ans la délégation soviétique
est réduite à sa plus simple expression
et avec au lendemain du discours de
ronald regan un peu d'amertume dans les
couloirs de l'onu voulant à bien marquer
que le président n'a pas prononcé un
seul mot sur les problèmes économiques
du monde et surtout du tiers-monde
on attend donc les interventions
successives de main du premier ministre
indira gandhi et de françois mitterrand
pour élargir un peu le débat qui jusqu'à
ce soir on sera resté au rapport
washington moscou et avec deux allusions
à peine à la sphère du boeing coréen
ronald reagan qu'on n'a jamais vu aussi
peu anti soviétique a voulu c'est
certain dès le début dédramatiser un
débat qu'on annonçait comme houleux il y
à une quarantaine de chefs d'état ou de
gouvernement en ce moment à new york
mais cela en posant c'est vrai les deux
questions que chacun se pose ici que
sont devenus les rêves des fondateurs de
l'onu
que reste-t-il de l'esprit qui a créé
les nations unies j'obéis entre anduze
ronald reagan a en tout cas bouger sur
au moins deux points sensibles
concernant les armements nucléaires
premièrement il accepte de prendre en
compte tout de suite dans les
négociations sur les euromissiles les
avions porteurs de bombes nucléaires et
pas seulement les fusées c'est là une
revendication déjà ancienne des
soviétiques et en ce qui concerne
maintenant les fusées et c'est là sa
deuxième concession il semble ne plus
faire un dogme de l'equilibre absolue
une fusée américaine contre une fusée
russe savourait surtout en extrême
orient où les américains laisserait
soviétique prendre un peu d'avancé sur
eux cette relative flexibilité s'oppose
à l'attitude rigide de monsieur andropov
chez qui on avait cru discerner un peu
de souplesse en décembre dernier dans
son discours au siège suprême mais qui
depuis décembre a littéralement gelé son
attitude donc flexibilité américaine
contre rigidité soviétique
l'opinion internationale devrait donc
accueillir plutôt favorablement
l'attitude de monsieur reygades le
président mitterrand est arrivé ce soir
à new york il s'adressera demain à
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
et participera à un sommet restreint
organisé par le premier ministre indien
manmohan dit en marge des travaux des
nations unies les
quatre ministres des affaires étrangères
des pays qui participent à la force
multinationale olive ans se sont réunis
aujourd'hui à new york pour examiner la
situation dans le pays au lendemain du
cessez le feu
le cessez le feu a été à peu près
respectée aujourd'hui sur le terrain
mais le comité militaire chargé de le
consolider ne s'est pas encore réunie à
beyrouth les libanais s'habitue peu à
peu à vivre sans les bombardements comme
l'ont constaté dans un quartier
populaire
jacquat bouchard et patrice du tertre
des halles de quartier à beyrouth un
régis miniature installé sous les arches
d'une voix à circulation rapide
débarquer des camions frigorifiques les
pièces de viande sont d'éviter sur des
étals de fortune en plein air
c'est la dernière trouvaille de quelques
bouchées victimes de la guerre leurs
magasins ont été détruits
il se trouve dans une zone inaccessible
le système d l'improvisation sont plus
que jamais des vertus libanais les
clients viennent tôt le matin à l'heure
où les combattants de tous bords
s'octroie un peu de répit après des
nuits à se tirer dessus et avant de
remonter au poste de combat
d'ailleurs le secteur est calme dévasté
ruinés mais calme c'est le centre
historique de beyrouth les batailles
féroces entre phalangistes libanais et
palestiniens l'ont saigner à blanc vidée
de ses habitants
les palestiniens sont partis la
population n'est pas revenu seuls
quelques irréductibles sont restés des
hommes qui se retrouvent pour une partie
de cartes
il commente les nouvelles et se félicite
que la guerre dans sa phase actuelle ce
soit transportée loin de chez eux loin
c'est d'ailleurs beaucoup dire elle se
déroule à la périphérie dans la proche
banlieue
et puis à la montagne à 15 20 kilomètres
tout au plus un quart d'heure de voiture
quelques contrôles militaires un no
man's land
et voici de nouveau les barrage de sacs
de sable les miliciens avec leur braquo
leurs armes anti char et leurs fusils
d'assaut ceux là sont des musulmans
chiites
ils ont fait le coup de feu contre
l'armée israélienne en 1982
cette année ils défient l'armée
libanaise ils ont transformé leur
secteur en un véritable bastion la
population ou ce qui en reste vit dans
cette poudrière au rythme des
bombardements quotidiens
les obus tombent n'importe où y
provoquant à chaque explosion une fuite
éperdue de quelques passants affolés un
vieillard fort
franck et repart péniblement profitant
d'un moment d'accalmie
un homme fini de charger sa voiture il
emporte ce qu'on retrouve sur toutes les
routes de l'exode des matelas des
couvertures quelques pauvres ballot il
n'en peut plus avec sa famille il fuit
vers le sud vers la zone israélienne
l'un de ses voisins
regardez préparatifs avec détachement
plus qu'une bombe explose
pas de mort mais encore un peu plus de
ruines la journée a été chaude certes
mais pas apocalyptique
alors les beyrouthins se terrent chez
eux et pensent déjà à ce qui les attend
le lendemain ils ne savent pas encore
que c'était le dernier jour de la guerre
elle était donc la réalité hier matin à
beyrouth qu'aujourd'hui le cessez-le-feu
était respectée et l'aéroport de
beyrouth pourrait être rouvert dès jeudi
si la trêve se confirme par ailleurs au
nord liban près de tripoli des
affrontements entre factions
palestiniennes rivales ont fait 12 morts
et une dizaine de blessés
les navires américains auraient battu la
flotte soviétique dans la pêche à la
boîte noire du boeing sud coréen a battu
le 1er septembre dernier par la chasse
soviétique
l'engin électronique qui contient les
derniers enregistrements des données de
vol et des conversations des pilotes a
été repéré au large de neil mono rond
c'est ce qu'affirment les japonais mais
ce soir le pentagone le dément honneur
aux kangourous ont un la mairie qu après
132 ans de suprématie les américains ont
en effet perdu hier soir à newport la
coupe de l'america à l'issue d'une
ultime régate palpitante où le bateau
australien a devancé son rival américain
de quarante et une secondes
plus de cent mille personnes assistées
tiers à newport cette régate historique
et l'ambiance était chaude ranger abel
13 heures 5 heures de newport
hier un départ de régate qui pourrait
paraître dérisoire cent trente deux ans
de suprématie américaine des milliards
de centimes pour une vulgaire cruche en
argent et pourtant pourtant l'amérique a
les yeux rivés sur ces deux bateaux de
la victoire de l'un ou de l'autre
dépendent l'honneur et le prestige
technologiques des deux pays dont il
porte les couleurs aux états unis on
s'angoisse pour liberty exactement de la
même manière qu on s'angoisse est en
france lors du coup d'envoi de la demi
finale de la coupe du monde de football
on a d'ailleurs raison de s'inquiéter
car australia qui a été dominé durant
pratiquement tout le parcours
australia est en train de revenir sur
liberty l'amérique ne peut alors pas
admettre l'éventuelle défaite mais ces
cris d'encouragement ne changeront rien
ce bateau qui va couper la ligne
d'arrivée c'est bien australia ii et
ceci avec quarante et une secondes
d'avancé sur le bateau américain
quarante et une secondes qui vont mettre
fin un rêve pour les uns un cauchemar
pour les autres alors alors c'est
l'explosion des supporters australiens
après 4h15 de tension que l'on a tenté
d'atténuer en ingurgitant quelques
litres de bière le premier ministre l'a
annoncé ce 26 septembre pourrait devenir
une fête nationale en australie le héros
c'est lui john bertrand le barreur de
stralka 2 il fait nuit à newport
lorsqu'il parvient après deux heures de
slalom entre les cinq mille bateaux
bondés spectateurs a touché le quai où
l'attend sa femme autre vedette la
fameuse qui que l'amérique découvre à
moitié et que les australiens de newport
proteste encore des regards indiscrets
et jamy mais cette victoire australienne
si elle provoque la joie des uns
signifie également la fin d'un mythe
pour beaucoup aujourd'hui dans le bateau
mais c'est le plus beau jour de ma vie
de riga qui quand même malheureusement
je crois que la coupe ne sera plus qu
elle ait pas ce que parce que c'est
comme une jeune fille qui n'est plus le
jeune fait l'objet de tant de
convoitises va donc quitter sa vitrine
l'america's cup est morte
il faut maintenant que vive notre alias
cup dont le premier voyage se fera en
camion blindé
et en australie ce soir la fierté
nationale tourne au délire un délire
très arrosée et pas à l'eau de mer
un mot du temps de demain brigitte sy
monétaire et bien nous aventurer à faire
un autre anticyclone pour le moment il
est fidèle
jusqu'à quand c'est toute la question
car regardez la photo satellite
il a tendance à se décaler vers l'est
conséquence directe les nuages arrive
par l'ouest
tout cela nous donne comme tendance sur
la carte de demain un brouillard dense
intense sur l'ouest partout aussi bien
sur les côtes de la manche que sur
l'atlantique avec les nuages pas qu'ils
peuvent très bien demeurer toute la
journée en certains endroits
par contre partout ailleurs c'est dur
autant avec toujours un vent de secteur
est qui souffle assez fort sur la corse
le thermomètre reste stable de 22 à 24
degrés au nord de la loire de 24° à 27
ce sera le maximum demain au sud de la
loire
nous saurons le mercredi 28 septembre le
soleil se lèvera 6h46 il se couchera
18h36
et ce sera la saint venceslas
saint-prest polonais claude sérillon
vous présentera notre dernier journal à
23h40 demain 12h40 cinquantaine de midi
dans la série médicale un dossier sur
les infections urinaires et un
témoignage celui du député rpr
robert-andré vivien qui rentre de
beyrouth
j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver
demain à 20h très bonne soirée sur
antenne 2